he even has to be Billy Dee son or they
went to a new planet planted a gross of
something that they just found a bunch
of brothers super excited that black guy
is a main character he's black I'm black
see no black guy hold the lightsaber is
crazy
a black stormtrooper I'm just like
George Lucas's wife is black the black
guy is the main character suppose we
have a lightsaber I was gonna be a Jedi
I gotta say I'm pretty excited very
stiff nipples cut ice out of gave him
the line of the oh my god my kids can
play with this and I'd be like yeah you
know toss it up this thing I like Luke
Anakin was pretty badass but this is a
black guy [ __ ] [ __ ] up
can I just got a week though food
dilemma black man representation is
everything a film really awesome
whenever I see a different racer from
different diversity in a sci-fi film
it's not existed which kind of sucks
we Lord of the Rings didn't have any
black giving me maybe the orcs but
that's what Oryx told my back in fourth
grade they've had black dudes in Star
Wars for a while but never is the main
character James Earl Jones Billy Dee
Samuel Jackson thank you most powerful
Jedi on the Jedi Order now my man Jon if
you think about Princess Leia in the
first trilogy women attach themselves to
Princess Leia if not gonna have any
black people in like future films you're
basically saying it's not gonna be any
black people in the future maybe next
time they'll have a homosexual Jedi you
got a line up in the toy though I can
relate to you I know you can't I am so
excited for this thing I should buy a
ticket
thank you have bigger brothers the Star
Wars that's all those Billy Dee Williams
I'm taking this
you